foreign
another question here from Emily on
Facebook how can minimalism help me
create a balance between life and work
especially with regard to working from
home
work-life balance conforms to work-life
boundaries
um good one man that's good we harmonize
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's going for the trifecta me you and
Mal he'll get there one day yeah I do
need that Harmony in my life
what what I noticed in my own life when
I didn't have work life balance is
because I didn't have work life
boundaries now balance is not really
creative it you don't create balance in
your life what happens is you disturb
your balance by not having boundaries
right no one who has balance in their
life is seeking work-life balance it's
always the opposite When Things fall out
of homeostasis when they fall out of
balance that's when we go looking for it
if you're riding a bike down the street
it starts getting real wobbly that's the
only time you start thinking about the
balance is when you're out of balance
and that's because balance is not
created it is the natural state and so
the question is how do I get back to my
natural state well the way we do that is
we set up boundaries that are
appropriate and if you don't have
appropriate boundaries and you don't
stick to those boundaries well then what
happens you trample all over that
balance you fall out of balance and you
start to feel that disease or that
discontent or that dysfunction in your
work life balance oh absolutely I love
when you talk about the the work-life
balance thing because it is so true like
we unbalance ourselves
and we we think it's like oh well we
have to find that life balance but it's
like no we did this to ourselves we can
undo it it makes me think how um Jess
Williams who did our Social Media stuff
I mean she had a kid she um came back to
work for us and she was out of balance
and like something had to give and she
called us up and she's like hey my life
is out of balance um I can't do this
anymore for you guys I love you guys but
you know I have to I have to take care
of my life and I have to become
rebalanced and we were I was so grateful
that she was able to like take that step
and like be able to like admit that to
herself because I know she really liked
her job I know she really liked being on
the team it's really hard to give up and
you know maybe you're in a situation
where you do have
um some kind of work thing that's really
thrown you out of balance you may not
you may not need to just leave your job
and I'm not saying that just didn't need
to do that but I'm saying like in this
situation like don't don't just consider
what just did but there's a middle
ground too so I would ask myself just
like if I was uh riding down the street
in my my started to wobble I'm like
looking at this bike like okay what is
making this thing wobble like what so
from your home what is getting in the
way what is making your life wobble and
that will help you and guide you to
setting up those boundaries in your life
yeah
minimalism sets you free from the myth
that hours worked equals value created
we have a culture of busyness and hustle
push push push sleep only two hours a
day get up at 2 30 in the morning work
80 hours a week if you can find another
90 work 90 hours a week 30 hours a day
even though it's mathematically
impossible because if you really want it
you'd find a way to solve that equation
that's the complete opposite of
efficiency efficiency is about saying I
will try to optimize for the things that
make a difference in other people's
lives I will optimize for serving my
customers and one of the great things
that going remote has done for a lot of
people it's helped them realize just how
much work isn't happening for 40 hours a
week or eight hours a day most of the
work that's happening that actually
creates value for companies and
organizations it's happening like two to
three hours out of those eight hour work
days but why do we why do we do it
because it's performative because if
someone sees you there for eight hours
looking busy well who's gonna judge you
right especially if your results fall
short but people are starting to go home
and it's one o'clock in the afternoon
and they say I want to go for a walk and
they look around and there's nobody to
look at them and say hey you don't look
like you're working and so they sneak
outside feeling real guilty about it the
first time I'm going for a walk at one
o'clock in the afternoon and they go for
a walk for 45 minutes and it's the best
45 minutes of their life they come back
home and then they crush it in two hours
of work that they never would have
accomplished in eight hours why because
they weren't performing and when you're
not performing and playing the theater
game of work you can actually get some
real value created those type of things
have everything to do with work life
balance because the more efficient you
can get with your work the more joy you
can have at your home and the better the
energy you're bringing to the people in
your home now let's tell you about a
privilege that I've cultivated over the
last decade or so and I didn't always
enjoy the work that I did there were
bits and pieces that I enjoyed of it but
one of the best ways that I found down
balance in my own work life is to truly
enjoy the work that I do to be compelled
by it so much that I'm able to devote
myself to it if you have a vocation or a
creative Endeavor that is so compelling
that you want to don't to devote
yourself to it you're donating your time
to this thing and you would do it even
if it didn't pay you very well oh what a
recipe for work-life balance because you
don't feel out of balance right yeah
it's like you're riding that bike and
you might be going really really fast
there's a lot of wind but still you feel
balanced or you can take a leisurely
ride on the bike as well and still feel
balanced but if if you start to feel
wobbly that's a sign that something's
out of balance here what are the
boundaries I want to establish and I
remember back in my corporate days
Ryan you and I we didn't have any
boundaries we were on call like doctors
we weren't saving anyone yeah except
maybe someone's broken phone every now
and then right I mean I had a bunch of
retail stores I was in charge of and so
in the middle of night I'd get calls 1
30 a.m all your alarms going off at the
Florence Kentucky store
okay what do I have to do now right do I
have to like get dressed and drive down
to Kentucky and sometimes the answer was
yes because I couldn't get anyone else
to do it right and so constantly having
no boundaries was a recipe for Burnout
if you don't have boundaries you will
become burned out if you want to avoid
burnout set up the appropriate
boundaries however you don't want to set
up so many boundaries that it's
constricting also if you just have
boundaries for the sake of boundaries
I'll put a boundary here boundary it'll
be like putting walls in the middle of
this room a wall here a wall there a
wall there now I can't go anywhere I
have too many boundaries what are the
appropriate boundaries that make me feel
free and I can operate my freedom within
those
pre -determined boundaries that I've set
not a boundary that someone else has set
for me yeah and that burnout also leads
to bitterness because the people that
are judging you evaluating you and
holding you accountable they don't know
all the ways you've compromised yourself
in order to say yes to them all they
know is that you said yes and when you
tell someone you're going to be
somewhere at a certain time that you're
going to do something all they care
about is did you deliver on the promise
and they're going to take you to task if
you fail to do it and so if you burn
yourself out and you negotiate your
non-negotiables just to say a yes that
you really can't fulfill and you really
don't want to say oh think ahead of time
about that resentment you're going to
feel when people take you to task for
underperforming in those areas set
yourself up for success as cliche as
that sound I think about my manager at
Applebee's who'd always say set yourself
up for success I triggered myself
however set yourself up for success by
making the kinds of promises that you
know you can deliver healthy boundaries
keeps you from being bitter and if you
give a promise that you're eager to
deliver even better I can't wait to
fulfill this commitment yeah as opposed
to uh well I'm doing it because I'm
committed to it those are the types of
commitment one is like a deep down
devotion the other is a tether right and
it all depends on your view and the
story you tell yourself about that but
are you committing to the things that
are a hell yes to you because if so then
you don't have to commit to it at all
you feel good about doing it did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalists private podcast
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com the minimalists or click the
link in the description your support
keeps our podcast and YouTube Channel
100 advertisement free